all right welcome everybody it's the
rare weekend stream because there is a
very very
important urgent coronavirus
announcement coming from donald trump at
the bottom of the hour
he earlier tweeted that it was going to
be at 5 30
sharp hopefully meaning yep here it is
hopefully meaning that we will not have
the requisite
insufferable delays important white
house news conference at 5 30 sharp
today very good news now the news has
already leaked
and that's actually why i'm here even
with this announcement i wouldn't
normally do this on the weekend
i've got my gardening going on i've been
prepping and anyway it doesn't matter
but the point is it leaked that the
announcement is going to be an emergency
use authorization
of convalescent plasma and anything with
trump and plasma you know
i'm going to be here for because we have
the potential
for donald trump to say the word plasma
potentially dozens of times or
it's possible that trump finally was
told you know it's plasma
um so that's why we're here and it's
going to be very very exciting i am sure
so i'm glad that you were joining me um
and let's see people are already sending
me super chats
um talio divino says david if trump wins
in november what do you think the
chances are of him getting us involved
in a disastrous war with another country
i mean there's always a chance to put a
number on it wouldn't really do anything
for us
um chakuseki says bloated populist
potato
admits in video that brian colfage took
cash from build the wall
how does this fit his narrative of
calling his arrest a political hit job
well he could be arguing that he hasn't
done anything wrong
and that it's sort of like a by
association type of thing
i don't know but i haven't uh seen that
that statement made
daniel krieger says is view count
increasing proportionally to subscribers
yes so as many of you know
we are heading towards one million
i'm i'm gonna try to turn the word
million into seven syllables
uh one million youtube subscribers now
estimated
to projected to hit that on october 19th
yes indeed views are increasing as well
we had our best month by far
from the standpoint of views in july
and we are doing really really well i
mean in the last uh
we in the last 48 hours the youtube
channel had 2 million views
which puts us at about a million a day
if we could keep that up we're talking
about 30 million views
a month and that is absolutely
huge huge huge for us so yes
yes yes yes uh we also reached 45
000 followers on twitch which is really
important we're heading towards 50
and we got the 45 and that's all great
so
really appreciate that um zachary foster
says david i love this idea that somehow
a major breakthrough
science announcement would be announced
by a politician plasma
yeah the other thing about trump
announcing plasma today
is it's happening in a whole bunch of
other countries
and it has nothing to do with the
elected officials like i have relatives
in argentina who currently have the
virus
and who work in medicine and they were
offered the plasma
i mean it just it has nothing to do with
trump that's what is really important to
understand and it's completely
propagandistic for trump to
try to associate himself with it and
zachary
is beautifully beautifully pointing that
out
ren holder says where's melania
okay let's talk about that so we have
now had an announcement
of who the speakers are going to be at
the rnc
i it's so insane so look at who's going
to be speaking tomorrow
senator tim scott who trump loves
putting front and center to claim to try
to claim that his policies are good for
black people because a black senator
likes him
house republican whip steve scalise
total bomb thrower
representative matt gates may be one of
the most deranged members of congress
short of only representative jim jordan
former ambassador nikki haley okay i
mean that's not as cartoonishly crazy
republican national committee chair
woman ronna mcdaniel total just partisan
bomb thrower
georgia state rep vernon jones i don't
know much about him or about amy johnson
ford
don jr's girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
natalie harp i don't know who that is
charlie kirk who's just a guy
who's known for being young and
supporting trump and going around to
colleges
and arguing with with children
essentially kim klasik don't know who
that is
mark and patricia mccloskey are the
gun-toting st
louis couple okay they're speaking at
the rnc
sean parnell i don't remember who that
is andrew pollock i don't remember who
that is
don jr and then tanya weinreice i don't
know who that is
either then on tuesday melania speaking
mike pompeo rand paul
kim reynolds you know it's just it's a
weird cast of characters and then eric
and tiffany trump they're bringing
tiffany out to i guess try to prove that
her and trump know each other to some
degree and have a relationship
you know the honorable kellyanne conway
is speaking on it's
nuts it is absolutely nuts who is going
to be speaking at this thing
and i'll be covering it because it is
you know it's only every four years so i
feel like it'd be weird if i didn't
cover it but that'll start tomorrow
night at about
8 40 eastern actually the one thing i
should look at is have they confirmed
that it is 9 to 11.
let me see here rnc schedule
when is it
npr let's see what npr had to say
here's what you need to know um
who's speaking and when
each night blah blah
this doesn't actually say what time it
is
i guess it's 9 to 11. from from what i
keep hearing it's 9 to 11
although i'm not really seeing that in
black and white anywhere so that starts
tomorrow and it's going to be a complete
and total mess
okay so ren holders super chat got me
off on that
thank you to jr dubs and dan tahaku
for the twitch prime subscriptions i
appreciate that
brandon white says bigly plasma day
love the show david thank you yes we're
all here for plasma
soldier of science says david what the
holy hell happened to your second chess
match it was yours to lose yep i just
blew it i just lost it
i mean listen my expertise is in
politics
it's not in chess i never pretended that
it was but um i am playing again
tomorrow so
there will be another match coming up
and it will be you know the good thing
is no matter what happens
we're gonna be okay i think that is the
uh
that is the good news uh for sure
sabrina safar
says david i sent you a 15 super chat
earlier congratulating you on the
anniversary you may have missed it okay
i did miss it sabrina i appreciate that
thank you
ophelia cox says dave why are you such a
grammar and speech
nazi when it comes to trump did you oh
and now it's been deleted by bridget
harding
okay i didn't even get to read it
wait let's see what i don't know why uh
please don't delete super chats by the
way moderators i i will handle i will
handle super chats let me see if i can
undelete it
no i'm unable to okay i still see it
nope it went away
okay uh moderators please do not delete
super shots i will handle the leading
super chats if necessary thank you
um okay
oh man lucky cat has subscribed
over on twitch m gray says please shout
out my black golden doodle
duncan duncan you're a good dog you're a
very very good dog duncan thank you for
watching
um oh speaking by the way
of uh the anniversary this is the
craziest thing
for about six weeks i've been promoting
that
today uh we're gonna have a huge
membership special because it's the 15
15th anniversary of the david pakman
show august 23rd
august 23rd we set up this entire thing
we sent out an email today to to the you
know to our entire mailing list it's
like 35 000 people on our mailing list
people waiting for this beautiful
15th anniversary membership special we
send it out hundreds of people just
start signing up it's like
you understand what i'm saying they're
just coming in like this
and then i i pull up the archives
because tomorrow
i thought maybe on the show on the
podcast we would have some clips from
the first show
today's not the 15th anniversary
i got the date wrong the actual
anniversary was august 17th
and we just missed it i mean so it is
this month
i wasn't so far off and it started when
i i looked up the calendar
and this used to be a wednesday-only
show it used to be every other wednesday
when we started in 2005 it was every
other wednesday
and august 23rd was a tuesday
so that got me thinking i logged into
our archive and i saw the first
the first uh show was actually august
17th
so in any case um
we we are doing this one day membership
drive and the coupon code is 15 years so
there's this on my website there's this
coupon code 2020 now off of memberships
it's 66 percent off
which makes them about 20 bucks the
coupon code
july 15 year drops it to 18.23
like 8 23 you know 18 8 23
because that's the day i thought was the
anniversary and it's actually not
whatever so the point of all of this is
you can use the coupon code 15 year
right now at joinpacman.com it works on
monthly memberships as well
we got the date wrong we got the month
right
whatever right i mean like what can i do
but please take advantage of that let me
shout out
some people who are doing that uh nick
kruger is new member number one
jean pacquette is new member number two
rebecca mann is new member number three
sustroski is new member number four
uh trevor zetterstein is new member
number five
um david morgan and christine vieira
are six and seven and eric mooney is new
member number eight so
you know what can you do i got the date
wrong of our own show anniversary but i
think it's okay
and you all benefit because we have the
coupon code
15 year which is absolutely insane
absolutely insane
um okay other super chats coming
in
um okay the message is back david why
are you such a grammar and speech nazi
it comes across as a bully did you mock
former classmates and students too
no i didn't mr lieutenant pink
congratulations on 15 years david you're
one of the good guys thank you
ren holder says is the rnc live any
chance someone goes rogue
i don't know how much of it will be live
and i doubt anybody will go rogue
educationy says is it possible for you
to turn down trump's volume instead of
muting him when you talk over him why do
you do it that way uh
it's hard to know if i turn it down if
the mix is right where you can
understand
and hear what i'm saying so we'll we'll
see we'll we'll take that under
advisement
michelle jones says kellyanne's daughter
just posted on tick tock asking
anonymous to hack
the rnc when her mom is on and stream
her whap
video or [ __ ] as some people like to say
um lucky cat has subscribed on twitch
calderash says david i count on you to
lead us to survival through the
rnc without significant loss of brain
power i'm going to try
i'm going to try dr whomever says why is
biden not campaigning in arizona
all i see are trump ads it seems really
weird since the extremely poor handling
of covid19
i don't know what's going i don't know
the strategy in arizona i'd have to look
into that
that chulo says hey dave do you think
the trump brother passed away of the
coronavirus because i don't believe
trump said anything about the cause of
death
certainly possible and plausible but i
don't uh
i don't know for sure waffles giroffels
says where did that go are you familiar
with the youtube videos by vic berger
yeah i've seen some of them
i've seen some of them funny stuff some
most of them the ones i've seen
mark anthony says thanks for all the
knowledge huge supporter pack
the bottom hashtag mental health
suicide awareness very nice message
victor jason says i watch the dnc but
with you doing it on your stream i
definitely can only get through the rnc
week with you doing it and congrats on
15 years yes
today we celebrate the 15th anniversary
of the david pakman show even though i
found out a few minutes ago that it's
actually
it was actually august 17th whatever
whatever but we do have a very special
one day coupon code which is 15
year which will give you the biggest
membership discount we've offered
all year nick campo
just grabbed one of those memberships
and his new member number nine
brian walsh is new member number
10. who else do we have
um richard erickson and justin chambers
are new members 11 and 12 today
and i also want to thank justin munoz
kasim miyan and max stahl
who are members 13 14 and 15.
i'm getting very very powerful uh
thunderstorm alerts because
it we have some crazy crazy
thunderstorms happening here in
massachusetts
if you're just joining us we have
figured out what the announcement is
donald trump is apparently going to
announce an emergency use authorization
for convalescent plasma
now this of course has nothing to do
with donald trump this is a treatment
that's been available in other countries
for some time
and trump's trying to get credit for
something
desperation we do have a hype train that
have le
has left the station spudnik 19 has
gifted five subscriptions um
vitality or vitality
subscribes with prime and asks if bonus
content is available in podcast form it
is
and margot cabot has also subscribed
over on twitch
um jacob ratner says i keep people
seeing people post about the pandemic
being over i can't tell due to constant
gaslighting
the pandemic is not over yeah if you're
asking whether it's over
it is not over it is not over
um let's see here
sometimes there's sort of like dud
questions
in the chat like someone on twitch just
asked can i
describe my background a little bit a
little bit
it's like i i appreciate all of the
engagement but
you know it's like what do you mean my
like ethnic background or educational
background
or i just don't even know how to answer
questions like that
john erickson says you seem to be in an
exceptionally good mood today you'd
really balance out
sleepy joe okay
jason nadal says why would senate pass
25 billion dollar bill knowing trump
won't sign it and senate won't pass it
on up
what can they do i mean you know should
they pass garbage
in order to get it signed that doesn't
seem to make a lot of sense
dixon side says your mods are upset at
you for publicly scolding them
all right well anybody who is displeased
with my
management of mod moderators can always
renounce their mod ship if that needs to
happen
um eduardo lino costa says as a
brazilian and you and argentinian do you
see patterns of this country veering
towards the mechanisms of third
world country endemic
patactasis god i don't know what that
means
but veering towards the mechanisms of
third world countries
um i don't know about third world but
things are definitely going
authoritarian let's put it that way
nick degamer says is it possible to
extend my
yearly membership another year with a
new coupon it is not
it is not you would have to cancel and
resubscribe
um
mp one subscribes with
prime and says canada's announcing the
new
conservative leader today hope it is
someone more moderate but not hopeful
not sure if trudeau can win a third term
yes we are following that very closely
nug wrangler has subscribed for 12
months with twitch prime
a lot of activity seems to be happening
in the room
um so we're gonna pay very close
attention to what's going on there
subscriptions coming in very very
rapidly
it's like someone has opened a fire hose
israel mckenzie and natalie lacastro
our new members 16 and 17 ricardo wilson
denise alarcon and daleville jones
get us to 20 new members um
also desiree de long rhonda allen
22 looks like we now have some live
uh audio that's alex azar who once hired
a
former labradoodle breeder to run
coronavirus response that's him right
here
and again we are expecting an
announcement of convalescent plasma
let's keep track how many times does
trump mispronounce it as plasma
okay he it may be zero somebody may have
gotten to him and told him
please say plasma please say plasma but
let's just see
how many times he says plasma and
remember
um this whole plasma thing has nothing
to do with donald trump
it's available all over the world it
just
it's trump trying to take credit for
something that has nothing to do with
him
and we will see if people fall for it
um shaner says thoughts on why trump
added 30 minutes to each night two hours
is daunting let alone more content to
produce
oh i didn't know that the rnc was
extended to two and a half hours
per night god that's not great i don't
like that i might just only cover two
hours
i don't know a bunch of people signing
up valerie
josiah josiah samuel lopez
says
rationality rules the stephen woodford
not familiar with that channel
bjorn eric knutson says happy
anniversary 15.
yes indeed thank you we are celeb we are
celebrating the 15th anniversary of the
show even though it was six days ago
i thought it was today so we generated a
coupon code
15 year which you can use at
joinpakman.com
dozens of people are doing it nobody
seems to care that it's not really the
anniversary today but i just got the
date wrong
i i didn't even know uh trump insisting
this would be a 5 30 sharp
press briefing one minute late right now
but i do anticipate he'll be joining us
any second here
waffles giraffe says a few moments later
q anon
aka moderate republican
rot kreutz says will this convalescent
plasma
reduce the number of fatalities i would
assume
it will particularly help yoseminites
uh reduce fatilities
you can actually hear a reporter
describing what's happening in the room
they must be doing just a very brief
live thing before trump starts
aaron green says david what do you think
of j.l kavan's trump impersonation
it's fan it's excellent it's excellent
okay we just had a real brief glitch
there that was weird
anybody notice that let's see if we can
get over to hd
oh my god trump is already live over
here that's okay i i think that this is
a better stream
so we're gonna stick with this stream
for the time being
uh usually it's about 20 seconds behind
and there it is right on cue
thank you very much and
it's good to see you all hope you had a
great weekend at your convention and
we're going to have a great convention
coming what
and i look forward to your convention
but before i discuss a very historic
breakthrough in our fight against the
china virus i'd like to provide an
update on the
recent wildfires in california and the
storms in the gulf of mexico
yesterday i approved a major disaster
declaration for california
spoke to governor nissan as they battled
two of the
worst wildfires in the history of their
state
that continues the federal government
has already
deployed over 26 000 first responders
and personnel to battle the wildfires
we're working very
closely with the governor and very
closely with
a lot of great state representatives and
local representatives
and we'll take care of the situation but
we have 26 000 first responders already
our hearts go out to the thousands of
families who have lost their homes as we
grieve for the families of two first
responders
and five residents who have tragically
lost their lives
it's been a very horrific
fire one of the the biggest we've ever
seen
my administration is also closely
monitoring hurricane
marco and tropical storm laura which are
coming in rapidly hurricane marco is
expected to
make landfall in louisiana tomorrow and
tropical storm laura is expected to hit
louisiana two days later this is
somewhat unprecedented the the scope of
the storms and also the fact that they
come so quickly after one another both
storms have the potential of gathering
strength before they make landfall and
could
cause significant damage across the gulf
coast and also in puerto rico we have
everybody
stationed and ready to go in puerto rico
and the gulf coast
and we have tremendous and tremendous
people
we have fema is lined up
we have the coast guard ready the coast
guard
has done a fantastic job they do so many
they do such good work and we want to
thank our great coast guard i'm asking
all americans
in the storm's path to follow the
instructions of your state and local
governments very closely
and i've approved emergency declarations
for puerto rico and for
louisiana fema is mobilized on the
ground and is ready to help they will be
in there very quickly very very quickly
and
i spoke to governor john bel edwards
also of
louisiana and i've informed him
and at his request also a major disaster
declaration is
signed and ready to go we have everybody
ready in puerto rico the gulf coast
louisiana and also on the forest fires
in
california so we have a great team
unfortunately we have some
very very powerful natural disasters
on the therapeutics front this is what
i've been looking to do for a long time
this is a great thing today i'm pleased
to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
the fda has issued an emergency
use authorization and
that's such a a powerful term emergency
use
authorization for a treatment known as
convalescent plasma
there it is this is a
powerful therapy that transfuses
very very strong antibodies from the
blood of recovered patients to help
treat patients battling a current
infection
it's at an incredible rate of success
today's action will dramatically expand
access to this treatment and i want to
thank
dr han and remember every every
country's doing this trump didn't create
this the u.s didn't develop this
it's this is global right now but trump
wants credit this potential
this is the only possible and and it's
only made possible because of
operation warp speed that is
everybody working together we're years
ahead of approval so we would be
if we went by the speed levels of past
administration we'd be two years three
years behind where we are today and that
includes and
vaccines that you'll be hearing about
very soon very shortly
we'd be two years behind on something
that's been around for six months that's
weird
to save lives we're removing unnecessary
barriers and delays
not by cutting corners but by marshaling
the full power of the federal government
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent plasma for
patients with
the virus through this study over 100
000 americans have already enrolled
to receive this treatment and it has
proven to reduce mortality by 35 percent
it's a tremendous number the fda mit
harvard and mount sinai hospital have
also found convalescent plasma to be a
very effective
method of fighting this horrible disease
based on the science and the data
the fda has made the independent
determination that the treatment is safe
and very effective recently we provided
up to
270 million dollars to the american red
cross and america's blood centers to
support the collection of
up to 360 000 units of plasma
poor in late july we launched a
nationwide
campaign to ask patients to have
who have recovered and these are
patients that have been incredible the
way they've
donated but these are people recovered
from the virus to donate plasma five
since then weekly plasma donations have
doubled
and today i once again urge all
americans who have recovered from the
virus to go to
coronavirus.gov and sign up and donate
plasma today
please it's been really
an incredible just incredible people
the country has united so strongly
behind this
and i'll go over the numbers but the
agreement look at what's happened
and the success that we've had that
people don't talk about the united
states has experienced the lowest case
fatality rate of any major country in
the world you don't hear
that the european union's case fatality
rate
is estimated to be three times higher
than that in the united states
europe has seen 33 percent more
fatalities compared to a typical
non-pandemic year than the united states
and
i just want to uh ask two of our
people that have done such a fantastic
job to talk about alex azar
and stephen hahn to say a few words and
stephen i want to thank you because the
fda really
stepped up and especially over the last
few days in getting this done
the results have been incredible and i
think you'll see the results even go up
very substantially so we appreciate it
and maybe i'll ask alex to go
first and then stephen thank you very
much now will they call it plasma just
to appease trump
well thank you very much mr president uh
thanks for the bold leadership that
allowed us to deliver this
very happy news today thanks to your all
of america approach
america has done more than any other
country to expand the arsenal that we
have to battle coven 19.
and thanks to early efforts by your
administration americans have broader
access to these treatments including
convalescent plasma
than patients anywhere else in the world
in early april early in our fight
against covet 19
the fda barda the mayo clinic and other
partners sprang into action to set up an
expanded access protocol for this
promising treatment
president trump is the right to try
president and he's fought hard to ensure
that americans can have access to
promising covet 19 treatments
convalescent plasma has been a tried and
true therapeutic method
in prior outbreaks but the president
wanted to ensure that we developed the
data to support its use
and this fda authorization is one result
of that effort
the data we gathered suggests that
patients who were treated early in their
disease course
within three days of being diagnosed
with plasma
containing high levels of antibodies
benefited the most
from treatment we saw about a 35 percent
better survival
in the patients who benefited most from
the treatment which were patients under
80
who were not on artificial respiration
i just want to emphasize this point
because i don't want you to gloss over
this
this number we dream in drug
development of something like a 35
mortality reduction this is a major
advance in the treatment of patients
this is a major
advance just remember it's all over the
world
and has nothing to do with trump our
arsenal against covet 19
alongside rem deserve steroids and a
number of other promising options
currently being studied
because of the president's operation
warp speed we expect to have other
new results and new options reaching
patients as soon as this fall
operation warp speed is supporting
experimental therapeutics
all the way through to manufacturing so
that if they meet fda's gold standard
for safety and efficacy they can begin
reaching patients
without a day wasted americans who have
tested positive for and recovered from
covet 19 can go to coronavirus.gov to
find out a quick
convenient way to play a potentially
life-saving role
in our fight no if you donate plasma
you could save a life we've also
provided guidance so health care
providers can contact patients
who have recovered from coven 19 and
give them information on how they can
donate
so thank you again mr president for
supporting this remarkable progress
against covet 19
and i want to thank dr han dr marks and
the entire team at the fda
for the speed with which they've
approached us the diligence to ensure
that this meets the standards at fda and
i'll turn it over to dr honda
okay mr president
thank you mr president for your
leadership um it's good to be here today
to announce
fda's recent decision from the beginning
of this pandemic
the president has asked fda to cut back
red tape to try to speed medical
products into the hands of providers
patients and american consumers
and i just want to echo the president's
thanks to the more than 17
000 men and women who work at fda they
have worked day and night
to in fact do that so plasma
is the liquid portion of the blood
that liquid portion contains the natural
immunity
that someone develops in response to an
infection in this case
19 i mean that liquid portion can be
extracted and for many years as the
president secretary azar said
it's been given to patients with
infectious diseases for more than 100
years
so there was a really good rationale for
why this might work
and in fact as was mentioned in early
april
an expanded access program was started
at the mayo clinic with the support of
the federal government
under president trump's leadership and
that has gone on for the last four
months
more than uh ninety thousand close to a
hundred thousand americans have enrolled
in this
uh program and over seventy thousand
have received treatment
this is one of the largest expanded
access programs
um in the history of fda so a very
successful
approach to evaluating how convalescent
plasma
would work so in the independent
judgment of
experts and expert scientists at fda who
have reviewed the totality of data
not just the data from this expanded
access program but more than a dozen
published studies
as well as the historical experience
associated with this
those those scientists have concluded
that covid19 convalescent
plasma is safe oh he almost had plasma
and shows promising efficacy
thereby meeting the criteria for an
emergency use authorization
in the optimal treatment of the optimal
patients as described by secretary azar
treated with convalescent plasma at the
highest titers
there was a 35 percent improvement in
survival
which is a significant clinical benefit
now we're waiting for more data
we're going to continue to gather data
but this clearly meets the criteria that
we've established for
emergency use authorization and we're
very pleased with these results so let
me just put this in perspective many of
you know i was a cancer doctor before i
became fda commissioner and a 35
improvement
in survival is a pretty substantial
clinical benefit
what that means is in in if the data
continue to pan out
a hundred people who are sick with covet
19
35 would have been saved because of the
administration of plasma
we've seen a great deal of demand for
this from doctors around the way
is that the right math or is it that 35
of those who would have died are saved i
don't i don't actually know that he's
presenting the math correctly there
demand and again i want to echo the
presidents and the secretaries uh
uh ask of the american people if you've
recovered from covert 19
please donate it could save a life and
mr president thank you again
that math might overstate the benefit of
this by orders of magnitude
that was really weird thank you mr
president i want to first ask you about
the kova 19 drugs that are in phase
three
are they going to be available to the
american population
on you and i talked previously about
this idea of
right to try right can we assure the
american people
that if it's being studied and it's in
phase three you have that right you know
that's a great question
and i'm not sure a lot of people have
been thinking about right to try we're
all waiting for the final answer
and maybe i could ask stephen but i
would say that right to try is exactly
if somebody is virtually terminal in
other words they're not going to make it
and if we have these incredible
therapies and drugs that are happening
alex i think it's a very interesting
question
i congratulate you for that question
because i think we're all waiting for
that exact final endpoint
what about that we have all of these
great seemingly great answers that are
ready to come out but
because of the process it takes a little
can we use some of this
early under right to try please so it's
a really good question
um and of course um it all depends on
the clinical circumstances and what a
doc everybody's treating the reporter
like a little kid who art just learned a
sticker
of any agent but if you think about what
happened with convalescent plasma
and the expanded access program this is
exactly what happened
this program so we have ongoing clinical
trials that are randomized between
placebo or an inactive substance and the
convalescent plasma
while that was going on we knew that
there was great demand from patients and
doctors
the expanded access program is a way of
actually doing that
and fits perfectly with what the
president just said about allowing
people to be able to use something that
we have now determined to be very safe
i think to really consider very strongly
yes sir i think it's fantastic yes yes
mr president yes
you should get credit for that thank you
mr president thank you that's very good
appreciate o-a-n o-i-n straight to o-a-n
convalescent plasma as a treatment has
been around for
you know 100 years um you mentioned
works operation work speed which enabled
this process to move along a lot faster
what into that what went into the effort
for this to be approved for clogged 19
and was that hold up
political in nature well i think that
there might have been a hold up over the
last
week to be honest i think that there are
people uh
this has been around for months trump
saying politics delayed this a week
by the way this which is essentially
just trump announcing that we're doing
something strong opinion
and that's for political reasons this
has nothing to do with politics this has
to do with
life and death so we are being very
strong and we are being very
forthright and we have got some
incredible answers and we're not going
to let them be held up because every day
is lives
and we're not going to let that happen
okay very good thank you
mr president um in announcing this today
he said that the fda
has made the independent determination
that the treatment is safe
and very effective yet dr hahn just said
it was showing
promising efficacy so so which of the
two is correct well i think i'll let dr
han answer that question
so under our legal authority for
emergency use authorization this is not
the same as an approval
but it's an authorization and allows us
to expand the access to this
and our data we know we're going to
continue to collect data
we knew that for all of our emergency
use authorization so for example
basically the question was approved or
authorized on may 1st
we're still collecting data and we will
continue to do that with plasma as well
so it's the nuances of the language
around the authorization that we use in
the legal aspects
it's a promising treatment it's not you
couldn't say it's very effective just
yet
so i would say that a 35 if you're one
of those 35 out of 100 people who
these data suggest or show survive as a
result of it this is pretty significant
for that person and their family
okay oh my god today we've been looking
forward to
thank you very much great question
god just bailing what on earth
okay um guys please don't leave because
lance from the serfs
is in the middle of a really big
fundraiser right now
and i want to um jo i i told him that i
would join
his uh fundraiser briefly so i'm gonna
try to get
into that right now um
let's see here where do i go
i'm trying to see how to do this
uh join the discord go into the waiting
room okay stand by i think
you might find this interesting and
we'll also pull up his the surfs
twitch and we'll see what's going on
there
this will be just something a little
different um let's see if we can get it
going
so we're pulling that up and waiting
here
i promised lance i would join yesterday
the schedule got a little wacky so just
hang out with me if you want
uh okay let's see
so how do i join let's see i'm going to
send them a message
hey i am here and waiting ready to join
anytime
so let's see we got that and then i
i guess he sent me a specific invite
all right let's see what we can do here
join the waiting room go into the
waiting room
okay let's see if i can figure out how
to do that
we've got a number of different
i just wish i was better with uh
with discord i don't really know what's
going on
might need his help somehow not even
sure here what's going on
hmm maybe i'll try sending a twitter
message as well
something just popped there man it's not
clear what's going on here
waiting room okay
i just don't see waiting room anywhere
is it okay i think maybe we're getting
there
microphone
hmm i can't really tell let's see if
he's
let's see what's going on my own
business you know and then suddenly i
hear that sound
you know [ __ ] yeah
let's see
hmm so somebody spotted me in their chat
to get on audio unsure how to do it
huh
oh wait am i on right now
no
oh wait a second something's happening
hello hello friend welcome
hello hello uh are you a content creator
or
are they sorry sorry is this who
mikey um mikey lugo um
this is david pakman just trying to join
lance here
oh uh the others are in the streaming
thing so you have to wait until you get
dropped in okay so what should i be what
should i be clicking on
lance said just when i connect to get on
some waiting room
okay um david you're having some mic
issues it's really um distorted and
creates like a dalek effect kind of on
it oh my god
can you try disconnecting and
reconnecting maybe
i mean um coming in
okay uh let me try that
all right here we go wow disaster
it's all crazy um let me see here am i
able to just join through our discord
six people in call but
uh okay i am trying wow imagine if this
actually
happens now join through the discord
that's what i thought i was doing
the serfs okay here we go
now lance says he might pull me in this
is just so crazy guys i think we're
about to have it happen
the right thing is donating and reaching
out and helping trans people wherever
they can because
at this point in the world it's
dangerous for trans people
and we have to take active steps to make
it better
whether that's through art or donating
or charity or
like okay i think i'm just gonna wait
and just i think it's gonna happen any
second now
um
let's see of course yeah
all right thank you thank you for the
solidarity gang
of course thank you so much thank you so
much for being here adhd again can we
get an adhd gang in the chest
oh yeah um i'll throw myself out as well
um i need to go to sleep anyway it's
around
midnight here in sweden i don't know
what is happening guys
um i'll i guess i'll just plug myself
real quick as well
uh and thank you for having me and all
and doing all this stuff it's
amazing really um so
i am from the youtube channel
transparency
we do a bunch of uh video game essays
and pop culture stuff um
which are which i've heard are pretty
good
um for a link in the chat so yeah you
can drop a link in the saving share
charity just so we have a big anyone on
the server can go in there so
anyone leaving just drop links in the
savings share charity channel okay
we have them there okay absolutely thank
you
what is going on here bye
i'll drop my links and then i will be on
my way out again okay um julia
um unfortunately mikey's getting really
lonely so can you drop into the waiting
room
as well um it's been nice to be on here
um
i'm luxander luxander1 on youtube if you
want to
see that um yeah i'm a non-binary person
that's
that's the whole that's all that's it
that's the tweet i think i just did
something
later
wait i'm sorry i forgot that i have a
smooth brain how do i
leave just hit disconnect
hit disconnect
you tell me how's it sounding uh fine
actually yeah
beautiful so i'm gonna move you into the
waiting room and then into the main job
let's do it right here all right here we
go
oh my god everyone here just a lot is
happening
coming on the house so i'm going to oh
hey vermin are you back
oh yes i'm back the the storm passed uh
it was pretty
oh really wonderful the the rain was
incredible
filled all our rain buckets and our rain
barrels
nice um watered all our plants so if you
wanna
do you wanna come do you wanna come back
in with david pakman
yes dude it's an old name i have i've
been trying to get enough subscribers to
get it changed
to gort or captain garrison um
so david and yeah vermin's back and
david you want to introduce yourself and
i'll bow the chat for a little bit then
are we am i on with lance now what i i'm
just not sure what's going on
yeah welcome david so you're live first
uh and thank you so much for being here
very very much david
lovely of you uh so you're actually in a
group call so there's a few other people
um i'll introduce them to you but first
why don't you introduce yourself to the
world
yes okay and i am also introducing you
to my audience at a much more
powerful audio level as well so
everybody can hear you
let me see if i know exactly where that
is all happening
um yeah the stream is a bit finicky so
it's
he sounds quieter in the chat yes indeed
well listen uh it's so great to be here
lance i think what you're doing is
fantastic
i know we had some misconnects over the
last couple of days uh
i i have a twitch channel and a youtube
channel and a
podcast and that type of thing but this
is not about me today this is about
what you were doing and it looks like
you've raised
nearly forty thousand dollars is that
correct
we're just about to hit 40 000 uh the
the goal was
five that's unbelievable
hello oh no i just i just heard a noise
which sounded like something
disconnected uh okay right i think now
we
everybody can hear each other
yes thank you david i i i i very much
appreciate that that's that's lovely of
you
how how was how was your stream how was
life are you doing politics
yes uh today there was a big
announcement about something called
plasma i don't know if you've heard
about it but
the president of the united states
announced that we will be joining the
rest of the world
in using this uh possible treatment
and very anxiously he wants to take
credit for something that's been widely
available globally for a few months now
i i was gonna ask has it been uh i don't
know documented means tested
is there any medical science backing up
its efficacy
well what's interesting is that during
his presentation
donald trump said that it is radically
effective
and then his fda director said it's
promising
[Laughter]
so you know you be the judge it's
somewhere in between there
well hey i'm i'm just happy he's moved
on from hydroxychloroquine
i think we can all be uh glad about that
exactly i think that that's
that's important has is he still
like basically capturing the world
supply of hydroxychloroquine
that i don't know but he's certainly not
mentioned it for weeks at this point
okay well that's that's good that's
progress it's pr it's absolutely
progress hopefully he will
focus increasingly on treatments that
potentially work
what were what were your thoughts on the
uh the dnc
i mean listen i think the format is a
disaster it's like how good could it
possibly
be with no audience you know but given
that
um i think it was okay i mean there were
some good
i think the first night was sort of
misproduced in some ways
the energy level fluctuated wildly but i
think that michelle obama was very good
um i think barack obama was very good
um elizabeth warren really wasn't bad
bernie was excellent at distilling sort
of the importance of what we're up
against here
and you know with joe biden i mean biden
did what he had to do
there were people on the left and right
expecting him to barely be able to put a
sentence together you know like the
dementia crowd and
he just gave a speech and he pointed out
what what the choice is and it's it was
sort of
uh it was it was remarkable in how
unremarkable it was
that's that's a good way of putting it i
i just i remember walking away from that
thinking the
the saving grace to what just happened
it's the fact that the rnc
is next week like right
underwhelming as it was i was like well
at least the rnc will remind us
what's what's on the other side of the
coin right now yeah
i mean i do think um that there's a good
chance that
the rnc's optics are better because they
may
put aside some of the social distancing
stuff and they may
bring people in and trump's going to
participate in all four days i mean you
know he
any opportunity to be on tv he's going
to be on all four days rather than as
traditionally as the case just on
thursday so i don't i mean it's going to
be
like that cup the gun-toting couple from
st louis is speaking at the rnc
convention that's how ridiculous the
premise is going to be it's going to be
comedic but there will be a lot of
people who watch it and will say
hey that's who i'm going to vote for in
november so it's like it's an indictment
of
unfortunately the more than 60 million
people that are likely going to vote for
the guy and anna canagoya beans
yes of course yes um oh by the way i
don't know if you know this uh
pacman you're actually online right now
with the presidential candidate uh
vermin supreme
oh is that right oh i hung out with verb
vermin in new hampshire in 20 uh
was it 2016 vermin
very good no maybe maybe maybe he's your
name alone
he's in the chat and he was speaking
earlier but anyway yeah my last memory
of vermin was
in was it keen or manchester it must
have been keen no wait no
manchester wait where were we we were
somewhere in the in new hampshire
and he was like he had groupies he was
walking down the street
with a boot on his head and there were
all these people
following him almost i don't want to say
it was cult-like but it almost was
it makes sense he's uh i mean he's
he's uh he's a man of uh man of mythos
to say the very
i would say so yeah that's how i would
describe it yeah i actually i
i streamed an interview with him uh last
week uh he did the entire interview
uh nude okay um which which is which was
interesting
for uh for tos and then uh he also
proceeded at the very end to show me his
upcoming book that he's selling
uh that features a very tasteful pony
erotica
right um cartoon pony erotica which he
then proceeded to show
on stream so i i had to toast the vod uh
so that it doesn't exist anymore
but uh it was it was it was a memorable
a memorable interview to say the least
toast the vod i like that that sounds
like a wrestling maneuver but it's
actually just like a tech thing
so i'm sorry are we not all naked right
now i'm just curious
i thought that was what this was about
yeah sorry uh vermin do you mind if i
sorry vermin uh david do you mind if i
introduce some of the other people in
the panel range please
do you want to go down from from top to
bottom i suppose
absolutely is uh lord here oh yes i am
here sorry
um i'm lord features i'm a video game
visual designer in france and
well i'm also a teacher and um
i would like to take this opportunity to
offer people in chat would like to
go into art video
video games whatever just hit me if you
have doubts
if you have questions about software and
such let's
let's do things
a beautiful message of peace and love
absolutely um i suppose yeah i'm next
i have met pac-man before nice to meet
you again pac-man
it's good to see you um we met on
austin's royale
but i educate on basically
gender theory and anti-oppression on
twitch
and my my main goal is just to make the
world a happier more equal and safe
place for everyone
uh i'm assuming vermin's still uh in
dispose so i'll leave it to
we're in hell um hi uh thank you yeah uh
nice to meet you pacman i'm a big fan of
your stuff uh it's really awesome to get
to talk to you
um i'm a small youtuber i run a channel
called uh we're in hell where i
sort of do irreverent uh leftist video
essays where i try and
take a sociological deep dive into the
weirder sides of a
right wing uh culture so i i did a thing
about doomsday preppers i made a big
deep dive into uh michaela peterson
jordan peterson's daughter
i'm currently working on a video about
reopening the economy and also talking
about mike rowe
and uh yeah that's the type of stuff i
do beautiful
you should actually tell some of the
lore as well because you have history
with
oh i yeah if you're a
that's not true no no no i don't don't
don't give me that title because then
people will hold me to certain standards
i am merely a commentator
you know what that's that's because
we've had like jordan all uh earl
i forget how he pronounced his last name
who is an actual lecturer
but anyway sorry uh you should you
should tell these stories so that david
pakman can then tell the world
yeah i mean uh this is uh i i mean it's
probably good that you're not a reporter
because this is i think would just
classify as gossip but i mean uh i like
went to elementary middle school and
high school with the
two peterson children and so i've known
them for a very long time
i had a crush on mikayla in high school
but um
yeah no like i've like i've i have
friends who have been
like in her inner circle until very
recently so i've like seen
a bunch of the weird uh like um back end
stuff there
like um yeah uh things like the
rider for uh the rehab clinic that
jordan peterson went to which they were
basically like paying like a million
dollars a month
to stay there like uh paying for like uh
24-hour masseuses and uh
like fancy obviously steak dinners every
uh three times a day and yeah i know
it's uh it's been a wild ride with uh
mikayla uh let me ask you this i'm
interested in this because you know
over the last 18 months jordan peter you
know
in the 18 months prior to the breakdown
jordan peterson started to you know do
quite well financially but from what i
understand his net worth is only in like
the three to four million
dollar range so how who who's paying for
a million a month no way
how he has speaking engagements around
the world 12 rules for life was like uh
the international best seller yeah
exactly like
is he really like despondent i mean
maybe maybe the date is wrong
i'm not really sure uh like this is just
uh like from what i've seen from like uh
friends and stuff i like i i do know for
instance that like michaela's like
actual job is being jordan peterson's
assistant for which she makes like six
figures
um and uh yeah i know she uh
uh i i don't know uh like all the
details of their like financial stats
but like i do definitely know that like
they were certainly making a good amount
of money at like his peak of popularity
um they were like uh my friend who was
friends with mikayla would get to like
go
backstage at like all these huge rock
concerts and stuff because they're all
these musicians
uh who were huge jordan peterson fans
and
yeah like he definitely had that rock
star status for a time i certainly doubt
he's making that much money now
but yeah that's absolutely insane it's
it's like it's
what does it say about society that
there were people who were like
this guy is so awesome we got to get his
daughter backstage at our show you know
[Music]
there's i'm not i'm not supposed to say
which band is but it's a
very large rock band who's uh one of the
members uh jordan peterson was his
official relationship counselor
oh my god it's not nickelback is it no
is that a slate on canada
how dare you i hope it's not phil
collins either oh my god
no no it's uh yeah that's fascinating
stuff though
his uh his recovery has been uh has been
a strange one he's still on the all meat
diet as well
oh yeah absolutely and i mean uh
like michaela is also very much a like
anti-massacre and so
she like they all have coronavirus now
because
um michaela claims that it was because
yes uh michaela claims it was because
her
daughter went to a park and must have
gotten it there but
from like for months like her instagram
stories have all been her like going to
nightclubs and partying in serbia
right so hey by speaking of which it
sounds like you know about this i
i only hear things every once in a while
but i i heard a reasonable question
asked which was
why was he in serbia anyway like why is
serbia the place you go
if you're trying to get off of benzos
right so i do know
a bit about this well they originally
went to they went to russia
because um i think so like i think
there's two
reasons one is that uh michaela's
husband the father of her child who i
believe she was separated from for a
time
uh was russian he was sent back to
russia and so i think
part of what influenced her decision to
sort of be like oh we should go to
russia
was that uh like uh she could like
reunite with her husband
but i also think that part of it is that
in canada if you're addicted to benzos
they tell you to like
wean off because that's the responsible
way to do it
yeah uh but jordan peterson if you look
through his work is
not a big fan of drug addicts he's very
much like a believer that
you know it is your personal
responsibility if you are
addicted to drugs and so i believe that
it was a matter of like
that wouldn't have been acceptable
whether or not it's for his fans or for
him if he like buys his own
if he drinks some koi i can't really say
but i think that that was a matter of
like
if i go to russia they'll put me in a
medically induced coma
which is like the manly way of getting
off of uh drugs
i did once hear when when it was i get i
don't know if he was first in russia
and then there was a move but in any
case at one point i heard michaela say i
think it is
that the russian doctors were the only
ones with the guts to detox him and it's
like what
what a weird world that we are operating
in here
absolutely i believe the move to serbia
was a matter of
uh i i follow michaela on instagram
because it's a sickness but
uh she's like was like very upset that
uh
like uh she and i are from toronto and
toronto has been
you know taking social distancing
measures like um you know making circles
and parks to be like everyone
don't you know make huge crowds and be
ridiculous
and she was very upset about this
because obviously this is an attack on
our freedom
and i believe like it was something
along the lines of in serbia they let
you just do whatever you want and that's
what we want
wow unbelievable stuff i mean it's
insane
oh david i just i just turned your
stream on and i see that i'm on your
stream you're on right now yeah
nobody can hear you because your your
level is so low compared to all the
other guests and people are flipping out
so that's why i've been trying to direct
the conversation so other people talk
because you're just so low
i'd rather i'd rather they get platforms
so go ahead
oh man i'm half kidding though
i mean hey i'm happy to uh uh talk about
uh
the peterson war for forever i've been
like
so darkly obsessed with this since like
since i started my youtube channel
well you know there's actually a very
specific question that my audience has
asked me a bunch of times
to ask if i know the answer and i don't
but you might which is the following
i don't know if there's this guy um he's
sort of an arbiter
of ideas he likes to churn ideas and
french press ideas and sous-vide he's
all about ideas
his name's dave rubin oh god they got
the banana video up on the surface
and um this guy dave rubin for a while
he had a political awakening which put
him very much
at close to 40 years old he changed all
of his views and it put him very much in
line with jordan peterson and he was out
introducing jordan peterson
do you know this very normal thing how
much
uh ruben was paid for introducing
peterson
i have no idea um no i'm so i'm sorry i
i can't uh yeah fair okay and if you had
to speculate would you be able to
[Laughter]
i mean i i don't think jordan peterson
uh
works for cheap he's got a lot of uh
he's got a lot of expenses he has to pay
his daughter to be his assistant
and his daughter's uh best friend to be
her assistant
uh you know he's got a lot of stuff uh
yeah
got it okay so we don't fair enough
that's that's fair mm-hmm no sorry i
don't know um much about the like inner
stuff on the uh their financials
unfortunately that's too bad
[Laughter]
well it's incredible that's true
oh sorry what was that i can't hear a
word lance is saying it's crazy
yeah okay are you on discord if you
right click my name you can up my volume
by double but that's probably the best
you'll get on my
oh yeah it's oh my god crying
i know i'm exceptionally quiet one of
the reasons being
is that uh my obs is the the thing
that's
adding all the filters to my voice to
make it loud yeah maybe a little less
nasally
um so you know what you can you can have
conversations with everyone else and
i'll just use the
the the medium of visual
no i doubled your volume and we are
better off yeah this sounds way better
this is a game changer
oh nice by the way what's what's the
lore behind this
pac-man because i i was i was sent this
video when someone said
you're getting david pakman on you have
to see the banana video and then
obviously half of the chat started
thirsting for you
um so this video basically it's
this is an old video and at the time
it was less widely known that a lot of
humans um
open a banana from the stem end which
really kind of smashes up that
the tip of the banana and it's such a
game changer it becomes sort of
unpleasant
so the right way is actually if you've
observed some of the great apes
eat bananas they will pinch the
i guess what we would call the tail end
of the banana
and then it just opens up and you don't
damage anything you get rid of that
little black thing that nobody likes to
eat and you basically get a higher
share of the banana
thanks for sharing the truth that's the
actual best way to eat bananas
yup this guy's smart he knows well today
i learned
yeah if you and if you think this is
innovative you should see what i've done
with with plums
no i'm kidding around guys
[Laughter]
um going back to peterson one thing that
i think is interesting that is like
very often overlooked is that i think it
was like a very big part of his
narrative that it was like
he was this sort of just normal uh
reasonable university professor who kind
of just snapped when
uh they they uh they tried to um
uh uh pass uh bill c 16 which adds uh
trans and non-binary people to
uh like have the same protections as
every other like marginalized group
but this is like uh he's been doing
basically the same thing
for at least 10 years now uh there's old
video of him going on
uh like public access ontario tv shows
and
they would have him on to give these
monologues and it would be him
it's so funny he's wearing like a fedora
with like and a trench coat and
just going on these long rants about how
like uh
western man is disappearing because of
these feminists
now they just want these uh soft-spoken
beta males and like
it's it's so wild to like go this deep
and this has just
always been his career right yeah it
seems that he's upgraded to a
three-piece suit but the ideas are
widely the same
mm-hmm um i talk about this a bit in my
video but i think it's kind of funny
that um uh in one of his um
uh old videos he talks about as an
example of uh western masculinity being
destroyed he talks about how
uh his son wasn't allowed to throw
snowballs uh when he was in elementary
school
and i went to elementary school with his
son and
i'm pretty sure i'm the reason that he
wasn't allowed to throw snowballs
um when i was like 10 i hit a kid in the
eye with a snowball
and like the kid had to go home it was
like he got like a black eye or
something
and that apparently like single-handedly
cucked western masculinity
wow good job yeah i know someone had to
do it
stunning can can i uh ask for one quick
insight from you uh david because sure
you know so much more about this than i
do
what why are why why are the polls
closing
why why why is donald trump coming back
uh
what what's happening well i think
there's a couple different things going
on
i mean i think number one when you get
to
closer to the to election day you start
to see a shift from
registered voter polls to a likely voter
model
and you know registered voters very
binary it's like are you registered to
vote or not and of course people could
lie
but likely voter um depends on
you know different people will different
pollsters will use different questions
and then
assess the answers differently so you
that can cause a variation when you
start shifting from registered to likely
i also think that um there was a bunch
of and i said this three months two
months ago
a bunch of the the advantage for biden
was that there were still a lot of
undecided so like when you would add up
biden and trump
neither one was at 50 in a lot of those
early polls but there was like you know
13 percent of people who just weren't on
either side yet
and and you tend to see that consolidate
around the incumbent which is crazy
given that
who the incumbent is um also i just
you know when you look at the margin of
error all along
it was never really believable that
biden was going to win the popular vote
by 12
right so i think we're also just seeing
as the likely voter model comes in and
undecideds go down
you're seeing more accurate polling
probably but
also i kind of have a feeling that trump
actually is consolidating a little bit
of support and that's horrifying to me
yeah that's that's the one part about
this all that kind of frightens me and
then the one part i don't really
understand
because i i'd always said that like i
think there's a certain point
like a breaking point uh amongst
americans where once like
the body count reaches the surplus
there's obviously going to be like
everyone is eventually going to know
someone who knows someone
yes has a grandmother who's died from
covet or as a family member who's died
from covert or something to that effect
so there had to be a breaking point even
for the most like ardent
mega wearing you know uh trump for
lifers
uh and i thought we had reached that and
then and then it seems more like things
were
somehow tilting in the opposite
direction i don't know that was the part
of it that worried me
i have the same fear and you know the
crazy thing is like
if trump loses he'll probably lose with
60 to 64 million votes
and if trump wins he'll probably win
with somewhere in the range of
63 to 68 million votes like either way
we're going to have more than 60 million
trumpists in the united states to deal
with
yeah no that's um yeah it's
absolutely yeah it's a terrifying
problem that like
that's certainly not going to go away
and
yeah like i remember uh right right
after the election there was an
onion headline there was something along
the lines of a terrifying future
man identifies as a trump conservative
and like that's very much going to be a
major voting block and
yeah yeah that'll depend on you know 20
even if trump lee
goes now in 2022 and 2024
you could still see like these trumpian
type candidates get elected
locally or even to the house of
representatives god forbid the senate or
something like that
um and that's going to continue being a
problem even if like removing trump is
the beginning it's like step 0.5
so the concern is that there will be
candidates that are similar to trump and
just a giant voting bloc that will vote
for them like what would you consider
the
characteristics of these candidates well
what's interesting is like what's not
characteristic about them in other words
before trump you kind of had these like
mitt romney pro-business low-tax
conservatives
and that's like a little bit of what
trump is but but not even really
and then you had the kind of evangelical
religious right social conservative
that's definitely not what trump is
although he kind of like pretends that
now he's against abortion after meeting
a kid he liked when he was 68 years old
and then you had like the liberty tea
party types
and trump cow towels to them but that's
not really trump either so like the
trumpian is sort of like they take a
little bit from each of those three
but it's really about just angering the
left and doing the opposite of whatever
the left thinks is good
and it's about getting reactions it's
about coalescing extremists like it's
it's not it it contains pieces of prior
conservative
conservatism but it's really its own
thing which is the craziest thing it's
not really a policy-based
platform it's like emotionally based
right it really is yeah it's like we're
against lowering
we're against raising taxes unless we're
doing it for some reason that we can
justify for something else and in that
case we'll get behind trump or we're
against vote by mail until trump says
vote by mail in florida then we're but
we want vote by mail
it's it's not policy based in any way
so do you have any ideas on how to
combat that or not really
well we have 10 weeks until the election
so the first thing is you got to remove
trump that's
that has to be the number one priority
because we're not going to we're not
going to disabuse 60 million trumpists
in the next
10 weeks but we could vote trump out so
like that has to be number one
and then after that it's a lot of bigger
picture stuff i mean it's about
education it's about media literacy it's
about
retaking control of of uh
of certain narratives and spaces it's
it's a big
picture thing but in the next 10 weeks
step one is just remove trump
yeah yeah i mean uh something i i mean i
could be uh a bit wrong
it's been a little while since uh 2016
but as i like recall
trump's like actual policies uh
like beyond just like the sort of
cultural enrage the libs
type stuff like he it doesn't differ
that
much from uh like the other types of
like the other sort of republican
policies
even just like he's like uh i don't
think any of the other
obviously none of the other candidates
in like uh who are running for um
republican uh in 2016 were trying
talking about building a wall but none
of them
like all of them had a pretty similar
stance on things like immigration
i mean is that do you think that that's
accurate do you think that that's like
an inherent part of uh like republican
politics now
i think it's more or less accurate but
also remember that with trump it's like
when you say what is trump's policy it's
like
there's the thing he claims is his
policy during the campaign
there's the thing he claims is his
policy during the presidency
there's the thing he actually tries to
do and then under tries to do
it's like he tries to do it by signing
some bogus executive order that will
never become anything
or he actually tries to do it by
building consensus and getting a bill
passed so that's like four dif those
could be four different
trump policies on the same issue and
it's like you know
pick the one you like and then say
that's why you're voting for him was
basically the strategy
um i don't know if anyone's had a chance
to do this can i quickly plug the
charity we're fundraising for david do
you mind
please um and if i'm too quiet let me
know
uh in your chat because i can get
someone else who's
more more vocally attuned to reiterate
what i'm saying
but uh we're currently fundraising for
maine trans net
it's the largest uh state level
trans-lead charity in the united states
most trans charities unfortunately are
usually run by cis folk like myself or
david
this is the largest uh translate charity
and they also provide
mutual aid and much-needed support
especially legal support and other
things to the trans community and the
most vulnerable members of the trans
community
you know at an incredibly crucial time
right now um they're you know obviously
uh disproportionately affected by a lot
of the crises that are affecting the
united states
so if you have one dollar to spare
please swing on by
we've got a tillify link going on on the
other side
and uh thank you so much for uh for
platforming us uh
david and and helping everyone raise
awareness about this really cause oh
atlanta did you explain a camp unicorn
yeah i could i could probably quickly
yeah i can explain if you want to you
can do it
[Music]
the only thing is i i don't know how
much is he yes he will be fine
okay yeah um yeah so yeah this is the
only one that can explain this fully
properly where you see camp unicorn is
like a halfway house for trancey
homeless trans people especially a lot
of states now having laws like against
trans people in various ways like
bathroom bills and
doctors being allowed to refuse
treatment so in maine is sort of
a bit of a safe space for trans people
in terms of that so it's being set up in
maine and somewhat someone was very
generous enough to gift izzy with um
a little plot of land so basically the
main thing is fundraisers for is to
basically build up like a little
mini commune or halfway house a bit like
the old star house
um from the the 70s um so it's going to
be like a place for trans people who are
homeless or in bad situations to go to
while they get their themselves set up
and because the sheer amount of money
we've raised as well um
is the amount of money as well for
things like a name change fund and
things like that that could really help
a lot of trans people out
so the more money we get the more sort
of different facets we unlock of
that sort of thing i think it's uh i'm
sorry
sorry sorry david no no i was going to
say
i think it's fantastic what you guys are
doing for my audience
uh i'm going to be signing off shortly
i've got to go deal with my cukes and
zooks in my backyard garden
they need attention um but um they are
they were trying to raise five thousand
dollars at twitch.tv
slash the surfs tv they raised 38
000 and are now shooting for 40 000
under 97 percent of the way there right
is that fair
yeah 38 819 and 1999.
and david would you like to hear the
cherry on the top of this entire ice
cream
yes please um this
this was provoked because the quartering
and i don't know if you're familiar with
the quartering
the uh the neckbeard extraordinaire of
the internet uh he challenged me to
debate
publicly on the twitter and said he'd
only do it if i donated five thousand
dollars to a charity and it could be of
my choosing
so uh so i said okay i'll do that
because this is technically my job so
this is gonna be me donating my time
right you know uh and so we we kind of
blew that out of the water so the 5 000
we reached in the first 30 minutes
it's unbelievable so we're gonna raid
you when i go offline
shortly for people who are watching me
on twitch but if you're watching me on
youtube or facebook
you can go to twitch.tv thesurfstv
um you you guys are killing it i really
appreciate you having me on
thank you so much david i really
appreciate you coming on and raising
awareness about this
uh that's that's really good use of your
platform thank you mm-hmm yeah
thank you so much for coming on it was
really great to get a chance to talk to
you
yeah great to talk to all of you guys
fight david wait before you go can we
get a trans right
can you get a trans rights i'm sorry i
don't know what that means
all right guys keep it keep it up and
we'll talk to you all soon have a lovely
day
all right take care uh there it is very
very exciting stuff
so over on um twitch we are going to
raid the surfs
tv let's do it that's going to do it for
me i'll be back tomorrow with a new show
and then of course the rnc
and then of course all of these
different things
um and it's just going to be it's going
to be unbelievable
it's going to be unbelievable all right
let's do it
you